le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
mariah carey a trouvé le meilleur film
possible avec sa chanson mythique all i
want for christmas is you
l'adie m'a réussi à s'assurer chaque
année une place de choix dans les titres
les plus diffusés au monde
plus fort encore cette année elle est
même devenue numéro un des ventes de
singles aux états unis notamment grâce
aux plateformes de streaming avec plus
de 15 millions d'écoutés de madère rien
qu'aux états unis c'est en 1994 que ce
tube mondial est sorti dans le cadre de
l'album christmas mais il faudra
attendre 2003 et le film love actually
pour que cette chanson utilisée dans la
bande originale connaissent une seconde
vie et c'est seulement cette année que
la maison de disques a eu une idée
brillante sortir all i want for
christmas en single une idée tout de
suite payante si cette chanson a
longtemps ennuyé maria elle semble
aujourd'hui en paix avec solide qui lui
permet d'engranger un véritable jackpot
avant je la critique est à chaque fois
que je l'entendais mais à ce stade je
sens que je suis enfin capable de
l'apprécier il n'y a pas qu'avec ce hit
qu'elles gagnent beaucoup d'argent les
produits dérivés sont aussi une grande
source de revenus et le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que l'imagination des
créateurs n'a pas de limites
résultat à marjah est de retour dans le
top du classement des stars les mieux
payés au monde
rien qu'en 2019 elle aurait touché la
somme rondelette de 96 millions d'euros
et sa fortune personnelle avoisinerait
aujourd'hui les 275 millions bref il n'y
a pas doute maria pourra se payer all
she wants for christmas
[Musique]
c'est incroyable alors quelques chiffres
quand même sur cette chanson elle est
écrite en 15 minutes et ça se voit de
605 millions nombre de vues et 60 noms
de reprise alors la même chose que je
veux tel que magali que mag la même robe
et alors et en termes 12 est là ce que
vous êtes assis parce qu'en terme de
d'argent ces 520 millions de dollars de
recettes générées grâce à cette chanson
milliards cinq cent mille dollars par
aurait muni plusieurs millions de
dollars par an passé c est valable si tu
sais c'est que voilà c'est imaginer que
chaque chaque année en décembre
ça me prenait 96 bar live aussi qui est
sorti en 1980 jusqu'à aujourd'hui il
n'est pas loin de 200 millions par an
maintenant
non mais n'a été jusqu'à un million une
époque le termine à 16 milles longtemps
quand même